Do you need some help?
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie! This
is going to be my Westworld season 3
episode 1 video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs they've obviously changed a
bunch about what they've done with the
series the narrative style so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes I will be doing episode
videos for all the episodes this season
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet obviously we'll do
top 10 and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the new
intro in the new simplified narrative
timeline the title of the episode is
parcei domine which is Latin for spare
us Lord spare your people which i think
is a reference to Dolores later in the
episode when she talks about the real
God's coming soon referring to the hosts
coming soon she only has five Cortex's
that she brought with her those little
memory balls that she stole off the park
last season the ideas that she's using
those to sort of take control in the
world also using the insight machine
I'll talk about that too because
obviously the giant looking cortex looks
just like the memory balls that they put
inside the hosts heads as if it were one
giant big host god governing everyone in
the world the new intro itself seems
like it's more about the birth and
evolution of their new cybernetic
species as doors also says during the
episode you also see a lot of imagery
for Rehoboam which is the name of that
giant machine that they were talking
about through the episode as you
probably noticed the narrative timeline
is much more linear than it was during
season 2 it's meant to be way simpler to
follow as a show so if you felt like
season 2 was really hard to follow and
unnecessarily confusing in the way they
told the story they tried to get rid of
all that for season 3 the cool
transitions that they had that white
graphic readout is just the Rehoboam
system that giant machine doing its
thing but number 9 the opening scene
in Burma off the coast of Westworld and
the other parks so the episode picks up
on the Asian coast land presumably
itches a little while after the end of
season 2 not much time has gone by we
meet a really rich businessman that
seemingly has a big financial interest
in Delos and the incight company which
is why Dolores targeted him also he has
history with her which she says later in
the episode we've actually met before as
she makes him relive a lot of his own
worst memories about beating his wife
because we learned during
season 2 the big secret of the park is
that they were actually using the park
to make big backup copies of every
person that would visit this was she was
referring to when she said I've read
your book the book is like that memory
cortex that they put in the host except
his base for a real person there's also
a lot of irony in the way they show you
what daily life is like for a lot of
these people how much technology they
rely on to do their daily tasks you
notice that the symbol for the insight
company - also looks a lot like the maze
from season 1 in season 2 of Westworld
the maze that the hosts use to try and
gain consciousness so that they could
jump their loops she deals out some
really twisted justice when she steals
his money his files on insight that she
needs to enact her plan and that also
tricks him into accidentally killing
himself the way he killed his first wife
so number eight we meet Aaron Paul's
character Caleb he just sort of this
regular working schlub he's meant to be
this military vet who's dealing with all
those post-traumatic stress they spent a
lot of time during his storyline talking
about programs and loops because the way
they're trying to portray the real world
is that they're all just regular people
who are also stuck on a loop the same
way that the hosts were stuck on loops
in Westworld so real people have kind
of turned into robots the way that the
hosts are actual robots so through the
episode his character goes through sort
of a quicker version of what happens to
the hosts during season one of Westworld
where they travel the maze they achieve
consciousness and they're able to throw
their loops like later in the episode he
says in order to move forward quote
unquote jump his loop he needs to find
someone real in the irony of that is the
runs into Dolores who's actually a
cybernetic being although technically if
you think about it she is a real person
I love the fact that he has a tinder
style app for crime that pairs him with
other criminals to take jobs it's kind
of like combining a version of tinder
with a version of uber I'm looking for
somewhere to do crime where can I do
that and earn some money
number 7 welcome back Charlotte
who's now in control of the dello sport
we're not quite sure which memory ball
she has inside her so we don't know
which host she actually is but it's not
really Charlotte it's really one of the
other hosts she's taking Delos private
and ramping up production on hosts as
part of Dolores plan because she intends
on using all those hosts to take over
the mainland so she needs them
building an army of hosts that she can
use they make a really quick reference
to the insight algorithm and how much
people depend on it for their strategy
in making decisions some of the board
members really hate the decision but
then Charlotte looks over and asks the
algorithm what it thinks of her plan and
it says it's a good plan so they're like
well see the algorithm told us it was
good so we're going to go ahead and do it
they also imply later in the episode
that there's some sort of relationship
between Delos and the insight company
and we also learn about Serac the person
that designed the Rehoboam giant device
that's predicting all these things it
seems like he's somehow connected to
Ford and the man in black because if he
designed this giant system that seems
like there's a connection between that
and what's going on with the software in
the programming at West world
I think that'll become more clear in
Episode two he doesn't actually show up
till episode 2 serac is a character that
just talked about during episode 1 but
it is vincent cassell's character
number 6 welcome back Bernard so he
shows up in a field farming it what we
find out is a slaughterhouse seeming
like he's just hiding out trying to
counteract what Dolores is doing but
he's also found this weird way to
somehow switch between his different
personas so there's like his base level
of programming as a host that has all of
his crazy abilities and functions then
there's the layer of programming of his
Bernard personality so they're doing
this very Marvel Avengers endgame thing
where he's found a way to switch between
being Banner in the Hulk instantly just
by pressing that little red button which
he does later in the episode after the
co-workers find him out and he has to
kill them he even kind of talks to
himself a little bit his other persona
please don't hurt them too much number 5
dolores his new mission to
infiltrate insight
I love the futuristic looking outies but
we find out that she's actually pulling
a fast one on John Gallagher jr. I don't
know what his character's name is or who
his father is in the credits it doesn't
list what the name of his character is
but he's being tailed by a company fixer
played by Tommy Flanagan we also don't
know what his character's name is yet
either but John Gallagher jr. is the son
of one of the founders of the insight
company and one of the people that
helped make this Rehoboam device the
Dolores really wants to gain access to
so when this scene picks up she's been
playing him for around three months or
so I love the really sinister way
they filmed the Rehoboam device when
they're seeing it up close and personal
for the first time like it really is
meant to represent this giant godlike
creation
so if Dolores thinks of herself as a god
it'll be funny to see these two gods
battle it out when Dolores starts
interacting with it
here's the thing though there are a lot
of biblical references and easter eggs
during the episode Rehoboam was a
biblical figure that was the son of king
solomon the grandson of king david and
he was the King that presided over the
civil war that saw the tribes of Israel
break off he formed the kingdom of Judah
so he reigned over this really crazy
chaotic period in Israel's history I
think part of the irony in naming the
device Rehoboam is that its ability to
predict a path for everyone is meant to
prevent that kind of chaos and civil war
but Dolores is actually going to try and
use it to do just that start a new Civil
War number four welcome to West world
mantis so you probably recognize mantis
palm Clementi F from the guardians of
the galaxy movies from Avengers infinity
war avengers endgame it sounds like
she's working for Dell O's the way that
she talks to John Gallagher Jr's
character they find out someone's been
trying to gain access to the Rehoboam
system obviously it's Dolores but no
one's quite figured it out yet till
later in the episode when Dolores allows
them to figure out because it's all part
of her plan this is where things really
start to go off the rails and get really
cool number three Dolores lets
herself be captured by the insight
people in order to replace Tommy
Flanagan is a host I thought they played
it pretty good during this scene they
make you think that they pulled a fast
one on Dolores they got her when really
she was allowing them to do this this
whole time they think her plan was to
lure John Gallagher Jr's character out
to do something to him but really the
person that she was luring out was Tommy
Flanagan's character to replace him as a
host that's where this point under the
bridge was that's where that happened
and also where she ran into Caleb so I'm
not quite sure if she meant to draw
Caleb out or if that's just a chance
encounter
I think we're meant to assume there's a
chance encounter she wasn't expecting to
find Caleb there she was really just
there to try and get Tommy Flanagan's
character so that she could plant a host
inside insight I thought they did a good
job of telegraphing how caleb was going
to take a job on his little cry
apt it would also put him into lorises
path but I love the way the rest of the
big battle played out some of you
probably sense where this was going
pretty early on they try to jab her up
with a bunch of chemicals then she just
immediately takes them all out the frame
zooms in on the dashboard camera and you
just see all the action take place on
that display as she runs over a couple
of security guards takes over another
one then goes after Tommy Flanagan's
character you also noticed that when she
calls quote-unquote the other technology
to activate it in the area to help her
out
she says wake up as if she's talking to
the technology like the motorcycle as if
it's alive real badass takedowns we find
out that Tommy Flanagan's character
visited the park at one point which is
how Delores got a backup of his mind in
order to create a hosts version of him
number two then caleb finds Delores
and tries to help her so that sort of
sets them on the same path and in the
trailer for next week's episode he says
I'm with her so he kind of becomes the
new version of Teddy but they also kind
of imply because she took one of Teddy's
memory Cortex's that she put Teddy
inside one of the other hosts two in
number one obviously Bernard goes
back to West world to find Maeve and we
get the post-credits scene
revealing that Maeve is inside a park
version of World War two remember
there's still a lot of other parts that
we haven't visited yet we'll probably
see some of the rest of those this
season so even though a lot of the
action of season 3 will take place in
the real world some stuff will still be
happening back at the park and it sounds
like everyone is going to try and use
Maeve in some of the other hosts like
Bernard to stop Dolores so it's going to be
a little bit of a civil war happening
between the hosts too you may have also
spotted the cameos from Marshawn Lynch
that was actually a pretty obvious one
but the game of thrones producers Dan
and Dave also guest-starred during the
episode they were more of a background
cameo but if you spotted any other big
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
include in the video just write them
below in the comments and everyone just
post your general reactions on the
episode my episode 2 video will post
next Sunday night so while you wait for
everything click here for that brand-new
Marvel spider-man 3 movie announcement
video and click here for the brand new
boys season 2 trailer with new footage
and new characters thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!